Technology might make
magic harder,
but, man, living in a state
with legal marijuana
makes it much easier.
To prove my point,
I went to a local pot dispensary
with my buddy Doug Benson.
Check it out.
We're here with Doug Benson,
aka High-dini.
Ooh!
Inhale this.
Magic.
[upbeat music]
(Justin)
Technology has changed
the way people get high.
Now, Doug, when was
the last time you smoked weed?
Like, including now?
[laughs]
Yeah.
Now.
This is a cloud vape.
It vaporizes it.
What makes this unique?
Well, that one there, um,
gets you really high.
This is
another smaller vape.
It actually plugs into a USB
to charge.
You know what else it does?
It gets you really high.
And I imagine, really, what sets
this one apart is, uh...
- Oh, that right there?
- Mm-hmm.
There's one thing.
[both chuckle]
- Yeah?
Get you really high.
Man, technology's amazing.
(all)
Oh!
(Justin)
Truth be told, I know there's
no better audience for magic
than high people.
[laughs]
(man)
Whoo!
Whoa.
[laughter]
[mutters]
One, two.
Right or left?
That's too easy.
Okay, that is too easy.
[laughter]
Um...
I don't know.
[laughter]
Right or left?
It's not in either one.
No, it's here!
Come on, watch.
I didn't do it yet.
Left.
Oh, still--no.
Wait a minute.
- [laughs]
- Where the hell--
Damn it.
How did you--
(Justin)
Imagine a deck of cards.
Pluck one out
as your favorite card.
What's your favorite card?
I don't have one.
7 of clubs.
7 of clubs?
You want that one?
Imagine the 7 of clubs
just kind of--
just kind of emerging
from your brain
as a thought into reality,
okay?
[exhales]
Just watch.
Imagine, just--
Keep your eyes open now.
Keep your eyes open.
Here we go.
Oh, my God.
- Oh, my God!
- Right?
- How's that possible?
- Isn't that amazing?
- Isn't that weird?
- How'd he do that?
When you said
7 of clubs, like,
you were thinking
of another card first, like--
What was the card you originally
were going for in your mind?
- I mean, how could you--
- What was the other card?
There was another card
you were thinking.
- Okay, okay.
- What was it?
- It was also a 7, maybe.
- 7 of what?
Maybe it was, like,
a 7 of diamonds.
Oh, no, I don't want to--
No, no, no,
watch, watch, watch.
Oh, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
- [exhales]
- Okay.
It goes right back
where it came.
- All right. Okay.
- Here, it's right here.
- Right here, right there.
- Okay.
Imagine the thought.
- And go.
- Ahh!
- Boom.
- [screams]
What the hell?
How'd he move--
That's--
I mean, that can't--
- I'm the devil, Doug.
- You're the devil.
- The devil!
- Oh, my God.
All of us saw that!
(woman)
I don't know what's going on.
[laughter]
Well, Doug, thank you.
Yes, thank you.
I've learned a lot today.
Aw, I'm so high today.
I don't know
if I'll remember any of it.
[laughs]
- That's the great things.
- It was great seeing--
We'll have to watch this segment
over and over again
from the right state of mind
like our friend Carla here.
[laughs]
She's happy to be in there.